JANET CONRAD: So
in 8.13, the way
that we assess student
learning, one of the ways
that we assess student learning
is for them to give talks that
are the kind of talk that you
would give at the American
Physical Society meeting.
It's a little bit different.
We give them three
extra minutes than what
you would have in the American
Physical Society meeting.
Nevertheless, it's very hard
to squeeze everything you've
learned into a 15 minute talk.
And what we're looking
for in the talks,
we're looking for
several things.
We're looking for how well
they understand the content.
And how will they communicate
the content, both visually
and also verbally.
And so those are
the three things
that we're really
trying to hit on as we
grade them related to the talk.
So the students will end
up giving four talks.
The first talk is on the
early set of experiments
that they have.
So they do three short
experiments, just
to learn a lot about
how the equipment works,
how statistics works,
things along those lines.
And they choose one of
those to give a talk.
And that talk doesn't count.
So it's an opportunity
to find out
what it is like to give
a talk and to find out
how I'm going to be responding,
the kind of questions
that I'm going to
ask at the end,
and how we're going to go
back through everything
and take it all apart and see
if we can put it back together.
Then they have three long
labs that they have done.
And one of those
three long labs will
be the subject of
their final talk
that they give at
our mini conference.
And so, in the three talks that
they give, what we're doing
is we are not just checking
all of the information
that they've learned to make
sure that they understand all
of the physics and so forth.
We're also helping them
rethink those talks
so that they can then
give an even better talk
at the mini conference.
And so I'm doing that.
I always do this with my TA.
So there's two of
us in the room.
And the lab partners are
together in the room.
One person gives
the 15 minute talk.
And then as we go back
through, the other lab partner
writes down all of the
comments that we have.
So that the other lab partner
can give the first one,
the one that was giving the
talk, all of our information.
So that they can
make the changes.
And so this seems
to work really well.
And they will also work
very closely with Atissa,
our communications person.
And she also goes through
the talks with them.
We videotape them.
So she can see the
videotape and then
she can go through the
videotape with the students.
And that really helps to
make the mini conference
talk really good also.